victor oladipo started his career in
orlando three years
as a magic player and now warren lets a
three fly
and continues his red-hot shooting and
brogden was able to do that
assisting the ball outstanding job but
it makes them go
they're smaller chris without having him
on the floor sometimes he
replaced aaron gordon how about tj
warren right in his face
well right tj warren i mean that's a guy
that's just
got a lot of confidence let you know
there are there are some extreme
storms down in orlando so if you see
some issues with the picture they are
working on that but again
down on the disney campus and another
basket for t.j warren from
just from a concentration standpoint you
see the passes have been on point
in tj warren is recognized early in the
defense
the whole different kind of feel for the
game he had 16 third quarter points last
night there's two more
falling in for tj warren he's got a
10-point first quarter kick ball here
just a really good job of gathering the
ball and just you know you're getting
that pain
[Applause]
got it let it go he had it at first and
warren again
that's a heat check that is a heat check
there because that's over about a hash
mark
and tj warren is just really good with
it this is a heat check
he's out there innis is out there in his
face and it doesn't matter see there
gordon got to the front of the rim go go
is
active today he's been battling a knee
issue and two more
and a 17 point quarter for tj warren
trying to guard turner so you may have
something on the back side and that's
the back side right there
cutting to the basket is t.j warren
augustine is back in at the point for
the magic he catches now
oh great help there you go he had three
steals the other day and
t.j warren was for a shot just a good
read here
by t.j warren fournier tries to get